[Music]
so many people here gave up on facebook
and other things
because they said it didn't work what
didn't work was your ad sucked
the platform's working just fine that's
why it's doing trillions you suck
[Applause]
you've got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
[Music]
gratitude is something that i nor all of
the rest of the world can give you
enough of so i just wanted to make sure
we started that with that because you've
literally impacted you know this you see
this all the time
but we can't say it enough so thank you
so much
thank you it's really nice to be here so
keep doing it please
uh so the this little game show we have
um it's it's a in an effort to
help people fix their businesses we have
real life
instances uh which you are no
in no way obligated to actually buy but
we have a variety of different companies
that people have submitted
um we have some revenue numbers we have
some major problems we have different
industries
and we would love for you to get in the
mine space like you just bought their
company
a portion of it did i get a good deal a
great deal dude
just trying to get the mindset down you
just you just got the rhino of all
rhinos
cool already charging hard um
okay so we have a few different
scenarios but before we do that i wanted
to make sure we
we don't miss anybody because of the
scenarios that we're gonna we're gonna
announce so everyone's gonna get value
out of there so i wanted to start with a
few things i know you're passionate
about
um and we can cover a few different
things so the first one is snacks
i know you like snacks yep so
um the snack industry is very
competitive
there's lots of ways to get your product
out there
yes so if you could start with the snack
industry and maybe parlay into products
in general
what what do snack companies you know
organic vegan lots of new opportunities
out there
to create a unique brand what do snack
companies
need to do to make a dent in people's
attention in today's world
so what it's a really interesting
question
at a specific time because to go very
granular we have an ios 14 update that's
coming from the apple phone
that is going to really change facebook
and instagram retargeting
ads that are going to take away an
arbitrage
in a lot of ways and obviously facebook
inc and many others will
innovate because when you take things
away new things emerge
but the timing this question is super
interesting right as
a lot of you know and i want to say
what's up to everybody on the virtual
screens i see all your
nice faces is that some wine in the
background or plants anyway
um did you see the wine wall i did it
was epic and uh obviously we have a nice
group here like look
i think for a lot of you and i recognize
a lot of the speakers and faces in this
room
there was an incredible arbitrage of
media and creative
on facebook and instagram over the last
six to seven years
i pretty consistently spoke to it
from a branding standpoint like i i
think
you know what's so amazing about
something like covet is you just get to
go off the hamster wheel and it allows
all sorts of opportunity for thinking
and one of the things no question i've
realized
in the last 15 months is like wow no
matter how i said it i don't think i
said it well enough because i think the
big deal
is i understood that brand was being
built
in these channels and i spoke about
podcasts and other things and a lot of
people executed and it's great to
see jim i saw here something like people
did things but
there was also sales and people were
very confused what was going on
in facebook inc and youtube and all
these places because
there wasn't a good enough conversation
between the differences between
sales and brand and you almost have
these two camps where people really
lived their life completely on cac and
ltv
and it was pure math and then you had a
different group
that was a smaller group that was
playing on brand
and if you're a snack company that's
young
you're more doing sales up front to
create
numbers to give you leverage for another
capital raise and things of that nature
and so
a lot of those companies those dtc
companies
really rode this wave the last six seven
years
eight years ten years on facebook inc
ecosystem while the big companies the
ones i work with at vaynermedia
continue to underestimate how much was
going on down there and that's why the
arbitrage was so significant
it's just a supply and demand game this
is what i built my dad's liquor store on
in google adwords
in the early 2000s the difference is
that was really just sales it was intent
based business
cabernet i show up arb
in social it was really brand and sales
snack companies are walking into a far
more
difficult ecosystem today than they did
three years ago
so when i think about how to generate
sales
there's a lot of ways that it can be
done and i think facebook and instagram
i think tick tock is a has emerged as an
incredibly important platform
for sales if you really understand how
to run tick tock ads and if you
understand that
it's the one place where creative is the
algorithm
more than other variables so you can
literally your third post can reach
enormous amounts of awareness
i think if i'm a snack company i'm going
very hardcore on micro
influencers i'm trying to negotiate
deals where i'm only paying if people
drove
sign ups subscriptions not for just
posts and awareness
because there's a huge supply of
influencers now so you don't have to
just pay for the post i think you can
get into performance based
marketing in long tail micro influencers
but i also think that
something that is going to emerge from
this market where you can't
you know run ads get you to my website
re see where you were on the funnel of
my shopping cart and then retarget you
as easily as i could years ago
i think what will emerge from that is
people actually caring more about
brand and i like that because i think
it's actually going to help people build
better businesses because i think
most people in the last decade have re
especially because there's so much
capital raising going on
and there's so much money in the system
we just keep printing it like it's
coming out of the sky people were
building
companies to raise money not building
companies
and my hope because i'm always
optimistic is
with this moment of a year or two where
people are going to be
caught a little bit on the easier math
it's going to make them innovate around
brand
if you're a snack company doing a if
you're doing a vegan or a health play
doing a clubhouse three nights a week
around
healthy snacks or healthy eating or
clean eating you know just more br
micro brand work i think from the sales
perspective i would go long tail
influencer and tick tock to kind of
close that gap on
the rising cost of conversion in a
facebook inc
aka facebook and instagram world love it
thank you so much all right you know
what time it is everybody i think
it's time for uh the official first
game show called what would gary do if
he bought your business
[Music]
how's my game show it's my first time
doing a game show
i like the logo okay so these are real
actual businesses real
actual people on this planet um these
are
not startups these are fully functional
working
so the first one is uh steve um
i won't name all of these people but
this company integrity cost consulting
so what they do is they are a billing
error and cost optimization opportunity
opportunity company so basically what
they do is they go in to
big companies and they help them with
their uh
laundry fees their cable their utilities
and they find where they're being
discharged
yep yep and so they go in and they find
this my
money and then they take a percentage of
that as their i understand the business
okay so uh let's see into the
i do i like i think it's a smart
business we
we we've used some firms through the
years on that front so i understand
you get it okay yes so uh it's just he's
a one-man
shop right now in 2019 he did 77k by the
way gross and net is the same
right now uh so 2020 he did 120k
his goal he wants to increase net income
to 300k
why it's a good question i'm steve right
now i
oh you're the the person's not here no
okay oh yeah
this is i mean just they're on the
internet cool so i've heard of it
um i think i think this is this is a
good point for everybody in the room i
think
right off the bat the reason i jumped in
there is that
sentence is the most dangerous part of
the question
arbitrary numbers of just acceleration
i understand that people are motivated
by that and i think we all have
different dna
and i i i think that you have to respect
those context points for individuals but
i do believe that arbitrary numbers of
growth
people take too literal and start doing
all sorts of bananas [ __ ]
to just hit the number that may hurt
them the next year or the year after
and in general i tend to get a little
weird when people just
have you know it's one thing to say i
want to grow
and i want to grow in a meaningful way
whether it is financially for me
if we're talking real businesses which
was so much of what excited me to be
here
like i love the practicality of an
actual business not a financial
arbitrage machine
you're normally playing long like it's
your family business it's your business
you're you know not most people aren't
thinking about when they own a company
of like okay i'm out in two years and
i'm gonna you know be on a
island and get a private plane so to me
that
that's an interesting little barrier is
it 300k because you want to put your
daughter through college is it 300k just
because you made up a number
the 300k was easy to understand the 77
to the one like it was a logical kind of
jump
and there's multiple questions in there
why not 630
you know what about more profitable at a
buck 95 from 177
what about what about 210 but no profit
made because you hired three more people
because you're gonna go to a million the
year after
like it's fascinating for me about
that part but keep going i just used
that as a proxy to try to bring as much
value in this talk
um so he so the biggest challenge
continues to be getting prospects to
realize that they might
be giving away thousands of dollars uh
that's
number one the second one this one's
interesting i feel like i have fun with
this is the egos
of of these cfos and whatnot that's it
that's right
we're already doing it right thanks i
think that's right rick
thanks rick i agree so a couple things
that i think might help some people this
has been a huge factor in my career i've
come to realize
i think it makes no [ __ ] sense to try
to convince people that are not
commensable
i i am fascinated by this obsession
to like get the deal and just keep like
like the the inkling of a no to me
and i'm out the like like the sheer like
mate like literally like the maybe like
i'm out
not worth it not worth it the time isn't
worth it
in a world of so many and so for me
this is a game about not convincing
which people fall in love with
convincing
this is a game of conviction he's right
by the way
as somebody who probably has some of
that ego when i first heard about in my
20s like i'm in my
you know people are going to struggle
with that the business model is super
interesting right they only get paid if
they do the work so it's like to me this
is about him building awareness
my preference is linkedin organic
content it's not quite tick tock but
linkedin organic for this room
is gold and nobody's posting enough on
it
you know i i'm just telling you that's
just the way it is in there
so he needs to build awareness so what
would you do you bought his business
i would run i would probably do 40 to 50
pieces of organic linkedin content a
week
and then another 40 to 50 paid
or uh linkedin ads to the general area
where we were if let's say we were here
i would also stand up
a weekly podcast show called you're
wasting money
and so that i could film that so that i
could make the ads
out of it so i wouldn't even care if we
only had seven people watching at first
i would want the content from the one
hour show where i would interview a cfo
or somebody from the industry or a
legend
in procurement or my aunt or whatever
the [ __ ] it starts with
and so and then i would use the content
from that to run the ads
so the podcast is almost a proxy to my
ad content needs because one of the
great misunderstandings of the modern
marketing ecosystem is that it's the
creative that's the variable of success
not the money you're spending on it
the media plan matters tremendously but
the creative is the variable and the
more at-bats you have
so many people here gave up on facebook
and other things
because they said it didn't work what
didn't work was your ad sucked
the platform's working just fine that's
why it's doing trillions you
suck you know like that and that's the
part that
people are like oh facebook sucks yes
facebook suck like it's a very
it's a very ego game you did three ads
you you tried it for one month or you've
been running the same video
that did work for a while but eventually
it doesn't work
and now you're like oh facebook doesn't
work anymore no no you had to refresh
the creative that ad ran its course
so i would run i would do podcast weekly
i would um in you know the best part of
having a podcast is you invite people
that you want to be customers it's a lot
more fun to email a cfo
in your local area through linkedin and
say i would love to have you on my
podcast to speak about your financial
expertise versus emailing her or him and
saying
i'd like you to use my company to do
business
so now you're doing a rule that i live
by which is called the
high school house party rule which is
the kid that was lucky enough in high
school whose parents constantly went
away
and he was or she was able to throw a
party at their parents house
instantly became dramatically more
popular in school
they controlled the party they hosted
the party
by having a podcast and inviting your
prospective clients onto it
you're hosting the party and it tends to
lead to actual relationship instead of
just a sales call
that's what i would do i love it steve i
really hope you're watching brother
uh solid advice all right good first
round we are on the second round of what
would gary do if he bought your business
i feel like you need the cloud to clap
when the
thing goes all right
[Music]
there we go and by the way whoever
turned on the lights if you can keep
them on i like the
i need the feedback loop so if you don't
mind that oh
thank you yeah very good all right cool
all right second business this is
anderson
uh nova cosmo cosmetics their product or
service
cosmetics manufacturers sold 100 through
retail distribution
and private label so manufacturer of
through and through private label
relationships uh unique selling
position high quality low prices gross
2019 5 million net 2019
4 million god cosmetics industry uh
gross 2020 300k
net 2020 150 k
jesus yeah uh goal recoup revenue from
2019. no
[ __ ] but
uh direct to consumer yeah this one
hurts and um
this one hurts because i've been this is
something oh this is interesting hold on
this might
uh went revenue went way down because
they were sold in and through salons
so maybe not even retail right as much
so
whoever's closest to the consumer always
wins
and is always your vulnerability if
you're not that person
so the thought of being reliant on
anybody else doing the selling for your
product
is so scary to me and a lot of these
companies obviously covid was such a
left field thing for this business
however those businesses and i've seen a
lot of these businesses sometimes
one salon group is 73 of their business
and then a private equity firm comes
along and buys it who also has
a cosmetics business and they lose the
account they're out of business
so look i mean being in the b2b
wholesale
business and then deciding you'll be
going to be a consumer-based
direct-to-consumer business
is like literally going from being a
penguin to a giraffe they're completely
different businesses
however that is the answer the answer is
everybody's about to understand with the
advancements
of the internet and definitely the
emergence of blockchain and nfts
that anything anything that sits
in the middle of somebody buying it
and the actual thing is vulnerable and
if you're the thing that makes it you're
going to need the person in the middle
less and less over time what technology
does is it shrinks the middle
it's doing it everywhere it did it with
bookstores it did it with
taxi cab service like it just that's
this is what's gonna happen
so but they're probably i mean they're
the main manufacturers so they are set
up
to do this well right the problem
they're not just the brand it's
great in theory but selling to like
doing a b2b
business call and selling to like three
people is very different than trying to
get the whole world to buy your product
you know so cool but now you're
competing with l'oreal
and you know elf cosmetics and you know
procter campbell
and sephora's private label and altus
private like
cool it sounds good but it for anybody
here who's in manufacturing and the
thought of going to
direct to consumer it's just literally a
different business
comma it is the only way you're
protected
there there should be no businesses
today that are producing for a private
label
or for other third party without
standing up their own direct to consumer
business it's just too important it's
like
not having life insurance and so
what does that mean that means
investment that means you have to have
you have to learn how to do shopify or
amazon
how to run ads on social networks like
it's
and and so what would i do if i was now
it's a market it's a i mean first of all
i have no idea how that business is in
business
right like it's either amassing enormous
amount of debt they had tremendous
savings
they didn't have a lot of costs that are
doing home like that business
is in a really really tricky spot a my
hope for them
is as we're reopening that salon
business is going to be there for them
but i think we can all agree even best
case scenario
after hearing those numbers what 2
million next year instead of 5.3
right but with every one of those
dollars they have to stand up their own
shopify and their own creative ecosystem
and have to build a brand there
just is no other option so building skip
skip the the startup stuff
as far as growing that brand in in all
the competition because
[ __ ] cosmetic companies are ever you
know everywhere now
uh what what is the thing that you do to
to compete with talk
yeah it's just all this ladies and
gentlemen it's always the same game what
is the
underpriced brand building or sales
driving
ecosystem let me give an example do you
know why so many people are called abc
auto because the arbitrage in the 70s
and 60s was
having a name with an a in it for the
yellow pages
right like like i don't think people
understand this has always been the same
game
it was just that the yellow pages
mattered the most when you bought [ __ ]
or needed a service so people literally
changed their name from like tony's air
conditioning to abc because you know you
show up first
that was the arp that's why you see so
many of those trucks through the years
so it's there's direct mail local
television procter gamble coca-cola
became who they became because of
television ads
they were better at it and went harder
at it amazon is the biggest company in
the world
because they were the number one spender
on google adwords the first six years of
google adwords
they that's how they built their company
they outspent the number two player ebay
ten to one
they understood that they had you know
i'm not a poker player but you know you
have the hand
where you know the math like you got the
hand that's what they did and they went
all in
and my career has progressed because i
have pattern recognition around that
and every time i notice the moment i go
harder and stronger each time
so for cosmetics 14 14 to 30 year olds
live on tick tock
live the organic reach is absurd
first video could get two million views
could like
so elf cosmetics is something that
companies should google and understand
what they've done for the last year
they've exploded on the back of it
so tick tock would be the answer for me
if we're going that grand or
and micro influencers i still think when
your business went from five to 250 000
you are required if you want to save it
and it's on life support to lay in bed
for six hours
and dm 650 people every night
and ask them on instagram if they're
willing to post it if you send them
product
and and if not how much does it cost and
literally keep doing micro deals
until your eyes bleed or go work
somewhere
because your business is in trouble that
investment is time at that point
we all have either time or money
so i'm shocked by people's non-interest
in allocating time so much of what's
been good for me
has been my willingness to allocate time
time is a true asset
intent of like that matters yes
great advice all right um so
the name was anderson okay round three
of what was gary do you think totally
different
if he bought totally different oh i just
got some goosebumps now that worked
all right uh next business jj um uh this
is a franchi i think i can say it blank
fitness it's a franchise
okay should be an interesting one he's a
franchise
he's not the ore it's not his company he
got it
yeah because he owns a few of them uh so
core fitness memberships personal
training your standard stuff but
uh and this might be biased
but cleaner friendlier than the
competition okay he gives examples
so he does say there's always somebody
to greet so picture
oh five-star google reviews all over the
place
so picture this this really is
you know the place uh goal increased
member volume
um biggest challenge is getting new
people to walk in the door
and join at enough volume at the price
point we're offering so it must be a
little higher
to connect our brand with clean and
the clean and friendly we're not doing
enough volume at the margins we are
selling memberships for
this one's tough because i need to ask a
follow-up question of like what are you
spending your money on
to drive subscriptions
where are people coming in contact with
the brand yeah i mean
you know this gentleman's in a cac and
ltv business
right he's got math around how much he's
spending and how many people's getting
and
how valuable is that customer he can
look at all his customers and see that
people hold on to their membership for
6.3 months and he can run that math
and then he needs to run it against a
plethora of different media and creative
outlets to find the arbitrage that
creates scalability
you know what you'll you'll you'll like
this so let's open it up to give more
value to businesses like it that are a
local-ish business
i think they have three locations three
or four so you know i'm going to
i'm going to service i'm going to the
well and i and a lot of you in here have
interacted with me for a long time
i'll have the same answers for two three
four years
six years until the next arbitrage comes
let me give you one local that works
tremendously well
i'm gonna go back to micro influencers
because i believe in it so much
you can this business should go into
instagram
search search its town
that it's in and the five surrounding
towns
hit enter the results will show top
posts
from people that tagged in the area
you've gotta look at every photo make
sure they're not visiting because you've
got some sort of monument or something
around
so you're looking for locals and then
you dm the local
and basically trade free memberships for
social media posts at scale
so he ha what he probably has is a gym
that's empty which is an expiring
asset every single day which means in
theory
he could probably give 30 50 100
memberships away
to in return for awareness and co-sign
from local celebrity so what i would do
in that scenario
is look at the six surrounding towns
click every post every day
six times a day search those six towns
dm those individuals
and say hey i'm the cleanest [ __ ] gym
in the world
you live you live next door i would like
to give you a free membership
for six months three months in return i
want you to take
three posts a month every time you're at
the gym in main feed
six in your stories one tick tock and
hand to hand combat do people
underestimate the power of social media
platforms
outside of the traditional marketing
that they think they're for
yep
i think people underestimate dirt work
too
people always look for scale right i
think people underestimate the dirt
my answers are the dirt i still do the
dirt
from where i'm [ __ ] lemon i'm really
in the dirt i believe in the dirt
i believe that if you want to build your
local business there's no magic bullet
i think three four you know what i love
you can train the person at the f
you know you know this with restaurants
and gyms they're like
these investments they make on employees
they're they're not good investments
right
your gym's not getting enough traffic
and you've got somebody at the front
desk
sitting all day to me i'm incentivizing
that youngster
from high school or college or whoever
with
training them how to do this dm thing i
just said and
and giving them comp on how many people
they convert
that will incentivize them more than
them just sitting and doing their own
social media work
that's so you know this is how i built
my dad's store you know what's fun about
my career is i've come from a lot of
different angles you know vaynermedia
was great for me because i have a
real mapping now 13 years later a
fortune 500 life
because i came from one liquor store
then i lived
in silicon valley ecosystem startup
culture now i'm
now i'm in corporate culture so you know
what's fun about what i'm saying right
now
is it really sucks i don't know how
anybody else feels about this it sucks
when you're pontificating or giving
advice
and you haven't lived it i'm telling you
[ __ ] i did
the difference was in 1997 when i would
run up to the little computer right
above our registers when nobody was in
the store and went into
e-robertparker.com and posted messages
on wine message boards i wish i had a
phone
i wouldn't have had to leave the
register and i could have done more like
you know
i've lived this hand-to-hand combat
world
and i know it works and the scale it
works at today
is remarkable but it just is putting in
the reps
beautiful all right get ready for the
next
round of what would gary do if he bought
your business
[Applause]
you're right you're right you're right
okay next one
uh osvaldo uh owns a manufacturer of
blankets and bath towels
me 100 cotton love it
um this one is this one is
uh different gross in 2019 was
20 million that was 10 million
uh gross in 2020 was 40 million that was
30 million so had a good year
also a manufacturer much like the
cosmetics
private label um they don't have their
own brand
so their goal is to grow a private label
manufacturing business
while launching a direct to consumer
brand and balance the two
yes very similar yes yeah
okay you're doing the same thing right
oh so they're challenged oh
this is this is different their
challenge unfair competition against
china making cheap products
how do they how do you combat that
sounds like they're combating it super
well to me
they're making 30 million dollars in
profit
i i think honestly and it's a good
opportunity
i've been fascinated and maybe this is
the case here
my intuition is what he's referring to
there is he's probably got two or three
or four
significant clients and every day he's
feeling the pressure
that they may go with a cheaper option
because that's what big retailers do
that i love when people cry in baseball
you know like the thought of like crying
that it's cheaper in china
without doing something about it like
going to china
and producing it there unless he has
some sort of emotional
attachment to made in america and that's
his religion
and maybe his strategy but to me
price is always a game like that's
like that's like a funny question to me
that's like i don't want to get wet
in this swimming competition of course
you're gonna have
like pricing competition so to me it's
do not be
it's almost back to the first one i'd
like to you know what scares me is i
can't double click into this question
that that business might have been
driven all by one bed of bath and beyond
account
i see this a lot i see a lot of
businesses
play ostrich life they've got one client
that's driving their entire business
and their strategy is to put their head
in the sand and pray to god they never
get fired
which scares me to no end especially
when you start talking about these kind
of numbers
there's a big lifestyle change between
30 million in profit a year and zero
and so for me i think they're expenses
are
exactly the same and when you think
about the growth there
and the speed of growth that is landing
a monster account
so i'm thrilled that they're thinking
about private label because that is the
way to amortize
china's going nowhere let me give you a
news alert
china is going to destroy america in
business it's not even going to be close
you might not like it i surely don't
feel like i love it
but it's black and white too much scale
too much organization too obvious so
you know i would go to china and jb up
or take a deal or build a brand or
position to
you know i don't think winning the whole
made in america you know it's amazing
what humans say and then what they do
with their buying power
we say things but we buy differently you
know we love to tweet made in america
but by
unlimited items that aren't so i don't
trust the consumer
on that front their dollars speak not
their social media posts
my plan there is to build up the private
label the pert the brand
and in parallel stand up at these
at this much profit i've got my ass in
beijing setting up shop
there you go osvaldo thank you for the
uh hopefully
hopefully you're watching okay okay okay
here we go here we go another round of
what would gary do if he bought your
business
your team just put like that on loop
like
uh okay so we have uh this is owen
uh owen owns a company named dixon site
development
um in 2019 you know what
rather than me saying this why don't we
bring owen up here
let's go owen why don't you come up here
and everyone give him a round of
applause
i like it
[Applause]
come on up here owen it's good bro
why don't you tell gary a little bit
about your company
all right so i also it all started when
i just found the passion in running
heavy equipment
and it all i've
started liking doing it and i worked for
a hardscaper
for a summer and all the money i made
from him
i invested it into a dump truck because
my dad i was 16 at the time he bought a
dump truck
and yeah we heard him
go ahead well i ran it through my dad's
company because he owned dump trucks and
i can illegally own it
so i was working and
had the dump truck running full time and
eventually i was like screw this i hate
working for somebody
this sucks so this
with school was all screwed up this year
i was like
let's just go balls to the walls and i
did and
ever since then i haven't looked back of
working for somebody else or
anything like that i love it did they
not notice that you weren't on the zoom
or [ __ ]
well i was i was actually doing the zoom
on the job and
it was it was put up like a fake you
well i didn't even turn my camera on
but yeah it worked out good for you so
what's the question
um what would you do to
like improve on or be ready for
turning 18 if you were me well what do
you want to happen
oh we do like site work and land
clearing and
blacktop work what's the average ticket
price of like a job
uh it really all depends on the size
like if we were going to
clear piece of land it could be like
anywhere from seven to twenty thousand
and when you say
you know improving at eighteen meaning
are you gonna go to college or just no i
well school's always been hard for me so
that's why i was like
i was thinking about a trade and i found
a passion and then i was good
pursue it good for you so are you just
trying to drive more customers
so you your business has jobs and then
you have to fulfill those jobs are you
struggling more to get jobs are you
struggling more to service those jobs
well
well
it was at first it was hard to get jobs
because my age and people weren't taking
me serious which
i knew that going in and i've been
around it my whole life so
i'd go to these jobs at first and i'd
they want to take me serious and
at some point they just all started
coming towards me and
they started working out and
i just want to pursue and have make jobs
for people and
make it so at some point i don't need to
go out and work i can just have somebody
else
do it and i'll just scale it even more
you meaning the execution of it yeah
so how close are you to having
do you have any full-time employees uh
during the summer i do
so is the question about that moment
where you start scaling where you're not
doing the job itself
is it about because it's a very simple
business which is awesome
you have a passion for it you clearly
grew up around it so you have expertise
very similar to me by the way um
you know i think what let me give you a
couple things that run to mind
one i think people in your situation
often
don't hire or make the financial
commitment to the infrastructure around
them
early enough they want to do one more
year where they can take the money out
instead of pay somebody 50k a year so
that they can
do something with that money so for me
any ability to like stay disciplined to
be more patient
to build infrastructure so you can scale
more instead of taking money off the
table
is normally the cliche thing that i see
that's made a mistake of in this
scenario
yeah which is like higher and build
around you
more you know one of the great things
like the reason my dad's liquor store
went from three to 65 million so quickly
was
i kept paying myself 45 50 000 a year
and so like instead of doing the cliche
thing that i think a lot of people do
which is
make get paid 250 000 a year so i got to
buy bmw when i'm 27
i hired more managers i bought more
inventory i ran more ads
and it compounded it too many people
want to take it off the table
especially at this age so i think when i
hear
that last sentence from you i think
hiring that right hand or right
hand man or woman is a huge factor doing
it earlier than you think will play out
all right and because it doesn't sound
like you it seems like word of mouth is
driving your new business
word of mouth and facebook really worked
too worked really good
i've heard
cool higher higher and i'll give you
another piece of advice i think people
talk about not hiring your friends and
family i'm
actually a very big disagreer of that i
think hiring friends and family is
incredible
i think it's up to the boss to be
candarous
right you know like and i by the way on
the record i struggled with candor
most of my career because i like too
much positivity i was too capable of
generating dollars
i hated the idea of like that i believe
it or not on stage i'm quite
and on video i'm very comfortable with
confrontation shooting it straight
but in real life it was a little harder
for me but if you're up front with your
buddies
and your friends like there's a lot of
great stuff that comes along with
building with your crew
yeah and so i would consider that too
yeah
definitely beautiful cool yeah
congrats thank you
[Applause]
another round of applause for owen young
17 year old entrepreneur
young gary right there i see it dude
yeah because
you know like him and i both had the
great fortune
and it's great fortune of being around a
business you get to see it you get
expertise i mean
you'd be stunned what i knew about wine
at 16. i mean
everything because i also struggled with
school and i'd go to school and
not think about i knew i you know i
didn't think i was going to go to
college my mom forced me in the end but
i just sat and read the wine spectator
in class
somewhere around fifth grade i realized
they just pass you they don't give a
[ __ ]
so i was like all right well as i just
like
sit in the middle of science class and
read the wine spectator and was like a
nice enough boy that my
teachers like didn't they hated it but
it was kind of this funny relationship
and
i would be me and make jokes about pinot
noir during
saturn talk and it all worked out in the
end
all right well listen that concludes the
uh uh body portion i don't know it's not
the right word but
core portion of what would gary do if he
bought your business
everyone give gary a round of applause
owen
all right gary here we go turn your
chair a little bit
okay these are rapid fire questions
these are real people watching right now
virtually um you can bear down we're
gonna hammer through these these are
tactical questions everybody out there
live or
well you're all live but in person or
virtual
get your notepad out these are really
good questions okay
first one i've been at clubhouse for a
couple months appears to be a great
space
for entrepreneurs coaches consultants
trainers how do you see the app
working for for and bringing value to
consumer products
consumers and companies you know i think
i think there's
it all comes down to storytelling like
if you're a beer
consumer package product company get
your brewmaster on there to talk about
the process
people don't want commercials people
want
information and it may be as mundane as
how you know i'm a big fan of how to
avoid how to avoid our services so i
think owen could
go on clubhouse and talk about like 12
things you should ask yourself before
you call
us to clean your spot that you could you
know once you start giving that kind of
value it's what i did with wine library
tv
i reviewed wines we sold and told you
not to buy them
that just is a brain [ __ ] from a
business standpoint but it it really
changed my career
same with consumer goods like talk about
the macro not your product if you're
selling peanuts or beef jerky or
sneakers
go higher about like halo effect it's a
it's a halo effect on brand but you have
to elevate what you talk about because
nobody's going to want to talk about the
peanut
they may want to talk about healthy
lifestyle alternative protein
you know weight lift like there's things
like that and you have to go higher
michelle asked how would you leverage
social media to grow your financial firm
knowing finra sec stuff you know we work
with chase
i work with tons of financial advisors
law is an excuse
don't break the law don't go on your
linkedin and say buy this stock now
like follow the rules but it's very easy
to navigate those rules
talk about tried and true do q a go on
linkedin live and answer people's
financial questions people think in
selling they don't think in service
and the second you make that shift
social will reward you dramatically
because the word of mouth compounds
better than it did
in the real world three decades ago
beautiful megan asks how
do we find great talent and develop them
to lead
the organization day to day so the
founders can focus on gross strategy
not the daily stuff there's a lot there
one most leaders when they ask this
question
are micromanaging their people because
they don't trust because they're
insecure
so people are in their own people around
mindset usually what's that brother
wrong people or wrong mindset usually if
owners
the owners are coming from an insecure
place of losing money in the micro so
they don't let go
so there's a lack of fear at the owner
level of letting go because if johnny
[ __ ] up we're gonna lose that money so
they never let go
which never allows for leadership you're
gonna have to
jump in the pool and swim you're gonna
have to take the training wheels off
you're gonna have to go in for the kiss
and all those things that we did in
adolescence
in business it's actually empowering
somebody and letting them go
right the other huge variable in this
is firing fast
hiring fast firing faster
and promoting fastest this is something
that's
i see a lot of people don't do i think
people overthink hiring
like they're gonna be the perfect hire
people lie
in interviews it's hard it's hard
references are [ __ ] i've never
called a reference in my entire career
you want me to waste my time to call the
three people you picked to tell me
[ __ ]
what are we doing i've never called a
reference in my career
um i have incredible emotional
intelligence have had this incredible
intuitive career
of predicting trends and yet have hired
an enormous amount of wrong people
you don't know until you know so you f
you hire fast because that takes up time
you fire faster when you know somebody's
not right
you fire nicely gracefully you know give
them some candle up front try to make it
work
but you promote fastest so many people
know after three months they have
something
but they want to wait a year before they
give a promotion it's a huge mistake
so there's very there's a lot there
that's very different than the way
most things do it that's a huge answer
to the scale issue of that question
thank you um well i don't thank you
megan does
uh rick says uh what is your best advice
what is your best advice on business
development and networking for people
not good at it
to hire somebody to do it the idea of
trying to make yourself slightly better
and all the energy that goes into that
versus hiring around your shortcomings
will forever blow my mind
if you can't whatever it can't then he
can't afford it then he's gonna lose
that's like me saying to you i need to
fight that ufc fighter
and you're like well you shouldn't you
should get that ufc fighter do it i'd be
like you're right
but then i said to you but i can't now i
have to go
well then i'm gonna get my face beaten
like like
you know there's some funny questions in
business like if you can't business
develop
and you can't hire someone to do it
you're out of business and that's okay
not everybody should own a business uh
beth asks how do you create an
entrepreneurial atmosphere at a very
large
bank you don't
this ideology of like entrepreneurship
is [ __ ] insanity it's like being an
entrepreneur in a communist country
it's not going to happen you know it's
it's you could create some nice
relationships
inside you could have a nice work
environment ish
an entrepreneurial environment means
high risk speed lack of process
forward thinking not overvaluing the
numbers there's no [ __ ] bank that
gives us
six weeks that is a ludicrous impossible
mission
uh i like this next one for multiple
reasons number one
his or her name is mace i used to love
mace uh
diddy and mace did it yeah uh can gary
riff on
urgency tactics i mean you run a
hundreds of millions of dollars ad
company also other things
everything's urgent especially in the
marketing world right advertising world
what are the what are your tactics yours
or your teams
for i want to make sure i understand the
question when how do we prioritize
urgent matters
yeah i'll elaborate on the questions how
do you
uh balance other people's urgency aka
your clients
with thing with your with your actual
urgencies
how do you negotiate that how do you
navigate that better word
the people that are in when you're in a
client service business
the account person or the partner
has to over communicate truth
because every time you don't you're just
creating a ticking time bomb
and when something goes wrong like
someone your team gets sick
and it or somebody quit or you fire like
when something goes wrong you have to
constantly update that person
you know i think that the biggest reason
most
i think one of the reasons we built a
large client service business in a short
period of time
is because i
am not interested in pandering to what i
think the client wants
i want to tell them the truth of our
capability and the truth of its timing
and cost
and it's okay if they're not interested
which they actually probably love
you know some do yeah i mean a lot of
people do love it because
people like knowing what they get in for
they probably like the conviction and
the confidence
other people hate it they like being
pandered to and things and that's
it's all fine it's a hell of a lot
better for us though
there's nothing more anxious than
knowing it's going to be challenging
before it even started
right and so and by the way this does
not come from a place of privilege
because we built a big company and can
say no
we did it from the beginning because we
just knew it would be a lot losing game
and i this goes back to something i said
earlier it's a big deal
don't convince have conviction
when you're not convincing you're just
moving on too many people trying to make
it work
when it's clearly not working and when
you're on the servicing the client side
of that scenario you're in for deep [ __ ]
all right one more question jackie asks
how do you see cancel culture impacting
social media platforms do you think new
platforms will evolve
because of it and will we end up a
divided economy
um or culture i guess maybe yeah i think
that's what that probably meant
so we we are a divided culture
because we've always been a divided
culture the only thing that social media
is doing is exposing us
nobody's been changed my friends this is
mirror life
you know so of course new platforms will
emerge but not because of the way we
treat each other
we're doing that on tick tock and
clubhouse right now they just emerged
this isn't a facebook and twitter
problem this is a lack of cordialness
problem which has always existed we just
feel this is always what people thought
and said to the tv you just didn't see
it we're just seeing
things now i think it's brilliant i'm
actually loving what's going on
i always believe that one step backwards
two steps forward i mean it it's tough
i'm not enjoying it from the kind of
day-to-day anxiety
but i'm very aware that in the macro
people look back at this era
as a starting point to betterness
because there's an exp you gotta
expose shadows and we've got a lot of
shadows and every society does and every
person does
and it's all fine and dandy but but new
platforms won't emerge
because we're not getting along um
it's because innovation comes along
things get stale right i mean
look do you remember four minutes ago
when facebook was just for college kids
now it's for grandparents right like you
can even feel
instagram starting to lose it's kind of
right you can feel it
you can feel it and so it will always
evolve because social networks are
really
more like cable platforms than they are
like anything else
they have their runs facebook inc might
have a saturday night live
run vine had like an empire run like
they have different lengths
and so you know
but but a divided culture doesn't mean a
divided people
you know just because people see things
differently doesn't mean it can't
coexist
we need to get we need to we're in this
deep
need to convince the other person to see
the world
our way i'm looking forward to when
we're exhausted of that ridiculousness
and find ways to have some cordial
conversation which i really
actually believe in but it might just
take a decade
all right so one last little piece
before we wrap up here
um this is noble con uh the no [ __ ]
business conference as you can see
unfiltered all that kind of stuff we're
all here to it's a lot of no [ __ ]
people up there
get it's uh
what is one thing you think a lot of
entrepreneurs or leaders need
to hear you know gut checks that they
need to hear
in order to be successful over the next
decade
that if you're looking for outside
validation based on your net worth
your blue check mark or how many
followers you have
you're ultimately vulnerable for the
game that we're actually playing which
is
do you enjoy your life and you need to
really
look at that because it really plays out
it is only sustainable for so long
to play an optics game for other people
to think you're successful
it is the number one thing entrepreneurs
need to hear like who
you know i reference this a lot i know a
lot of people here
because i see some faces are close to my
content i reference a very obscure part
of the cinematic classic rocky iv
and in rocky iv which is the one where
he fights drago the russian
the russian at the end talks about this
thing they fight
rocky wins the crowd you know and drago
grabs the mic and he goes
look all of you in this russian crowd
you thought it was russia versus america
in this ring i was fighting for myself
in here [ __ ] you
and that's how i think about my business
i'm so appreciative of the love
the admiration but my inability to hear
that
is why i'm able to deal with the
negative pushback
that i'm like this that i'm a that and
it makes it very quiet for me
and then i get to play my game i think
the biggest thing that people need to
hear is you will
always lose if you're doing it for them
always it's just not sustainable in the
end
and i want people to be happier like
it matters like your quality of like
mental happiness matters and i think
people think money
closes the gap on it and i actually
think much like social media it exposes
it
i think if you're unhappy money will
expose it make it more unhappy
it will not close the gap and so doing
it for yourself
which is so awesome i i assume a lot of
you in this room and on video
probably know the thing i know which is
holy crap
business is my favorite hobby like i
would much rather
do a business meeting than golf it's not
even close
i would much rather have a business
problem
that i have to solve than go skiing
or take a trip to a vineyard i just
enjoy it literally the only thing in my
life that gives me
the same kind of like feeling is not
even going to a jets game because that
is actually escapism
that is like my church that like caring
so much about something that in theory
you shouldn't care about
actually helps everything work for me
it's actually garage sailing
this is real this is how i know i'm in a
very sick place
of like loving my thing the only thing
in the world
that gets my chemicals going the same
way every day does running businesses
is waking up at six o'clock on a
saturday
with like a 33 you know garage sale town
wide garage sale
and it's still just business it's
finding something for 40 cents that i
know is eight bucks
or eight something that's eight bucks
that and and so that's when i knew
that's when i knew um that
that's when i knew that um that bus
right i found my true love and
honestly i think for a lot of you in
this room and on video
debating how much you you may love
business and you like me love being an
entrepreneur but do you love the thing
you're doing
because if you don't
having the humility to take a step
backwards financially
to reset and do something you like more
is something that i'm trying to talk a
lot about more
because i've seen it i've seen it
ironically not because the person
usually had enough humility to pull it
off
it's because they were forced to because
[ __ ] went bad and they're like oh my god
i wish this did this 12 years ago this
is so much more fun i like this thing
trying to find something you love
it really works and so i don't know i'm
i'm
i'm really hopeful that people i mean
i'm blown away by how
status money follow count blue check
marks
mercedes-benz's rolex's like private pla
i
i
i don't think i because i was in my own
cocoon for so long
i don't think i understood how much
people needed outside affirmation
to be a band-aid for their emotional
instabilities or insecurities that they
were parented with or things that nature
and and i come with such gratitude that
i didn't
stumble into that but then almost a love
to be very frank
almost a level of guilt that i didn't
stumble into that
and so grateful it's like this very
weird kissing cousin of like
guilt and gratitude that makes me
desperately want to communicate it
on the platform that i have of like like
i don't know how many very very very
very wealthy people you know
but a shocking amount of them are not
super pumped
not super happy not living the dream you
know and so
it's not going to be money so fake you
know
figure it out and by the way we made a
subtle point earlier and i saw some
people react
i'm going to throw a weird one which is
also not fun to say but could lead to so
much more happiness
i believe there's a lot of people
watching are in this room right now that
shouldn't be number ones
that are like in between a one and a two
and like don't have the stomach or like
the leadership to really be a true
number one entrepreneur
i know that's a weird thing to say and i
don't say it as a negative i just see
so many people that are playing a number
two role making way more money and
loving life so much more
after they stopped trying to be a number
one for the optics of it or the ideology
of it
so that's very much on my mind as well
ladies and gentlemen gary vaynerchuk
is no [ __ ] youtuber what's up it's
garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times uh i also want to ask you please
subscribe because my
commitment and exploration of youtube is
about to explode stories polls
more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon
you